hey what's up everybody it's Warren and
we have some new plot details about the
Loki series coming to Disney Plus if
you're not aware of what Disney Plus is
it's Disney's new streaming service
that's supposed to be here by the end of
this year along with a Loki series we're
supposed to get a falcon and Bucky
series and a vision and Scarlet Witch
series as well and although not much is
really known about these new series
coming to Disney Plus we did learn a
little bit more about the Loki series
plot The Hollywood Reporter gave us a
little bit of insight about the new show
saying that it will follow Loki as the
trickster and shapeshifter pops up
throughout human history as unlikely
influencer on historical events this is
really cool Loki's gonna pop up through
historical events on earth because it
does say humans and he's an Asgardian
kind of since it says Loki will pop out
throughout human history we may find out
that Loki is actually responsible for
some of the events in the MCU that we
didn't know about and although we're not
really sure if this takes place before
or after the events of Avengers infinity
war where Loki died supposedly we do
know that Avengers endgame is supposed
to be kind of centered around the
quantum realm and perhaps time-travel so
it'll be cool to see what effects the
events of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in-game have on this show as
well as the Falcon and Bucky Show and
the vision and Scarlet Witch show as
well
if these shows do in fact tie into the
MCU but we do know a little bit more
about the show now and it sounds like
it's going to be a really good series
Loki is a huge fan favorite character so
it's good to see a TV series that's
going to be all about him so let me know
what you think about these new plot
details for the new locatio on Disney
Plus let me know in the comments down
below and don't forget I started a new
giveaway if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win five imax tickets so you
and some friends can go see Captain
Marvel or Avengers in-game in IMAX all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel with the notifications turned on
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain I feel like I'm
going to see a lot of Loki's show up a
comment section of this video today and
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]